[Music]
all right thank you for stopping in for
chess openings explained abridged we've
got some good feedback on our first one
over the dragon defense but today we're
going to go over from an opening from
White's perspective and the reuleaux PES
it's going to be the Brier variation not
the best variation for black but I like
to show this opening to try and give
good opening principles so that's we're
going to be focusing on today just the
principles behind the movements the
route Lopez starts off with a king pawn
to e4 e5 and a Knight f3 attacking
blacks weak pawn black protects it while
developing a piece this is a very strong
move because it like I said it protects
upon while developing a piece other
openings you might see are the Philidor
after a d6 and after d6 this can be a
little passive because you can just
break in the center but we're not going
to go over that today
nice e6 developing a piece protecting
the pot and what makes it the real Lopez
is what white puts his bishop on b5
other moves the other common move here
is a Bishop to c4 which is the Italian
which is similar but not the same Bishop
to b5 tries to put pressure on the
knight which is protecting a5 so that
way white can try and take the pawn
black plays a6 trying to kick the bishop
away and we're going to move it back to
a four this is the Morphy defense now
from black after a six they're going to
go Knight f6 and attack White's weak
pawn on e4 and here Y is going to castle
and this may look strange at first
because it looks like the pawn is still
hanging but if we go into this line of
Knight takes e4 White has a move rook e1
this is still very playable but you are
forking or yeah forking the knight and
pawn Knight moves Bishop takes c6 and
you remove the defender of the e5 pawn
so you can take it with your knight the
material is equal
the main move here is Bishop e7 trying
to develop more pieces and castle
why does already Castle so black is
trying to catch up in that regard
because now there's no pin to the King
on the e-file we put the rook on e one
so that we can protect our pawn and then
black plays B five before castling they
want to kick the bishop away again so we
played Bishop to b3 and then the most
common move here is d6 if you are
playing this as white be careful of the
marshal attack if they play d6 first
they play d6 first they can lead to the
marshal the other move they can play
instead of d6 is Castle in which case we
just continue as normal after d6 you
play c3 and then black is going to
Castle here it's now both sides have
capsuled they're both trying to develop
their pieces and now it's going to be a
fight over center control and who has
better placed pieces here white goes h3
to prevent Bishop to g4 pinning the
knight to the Queen so h3 prevents that
and then Knight to b8 this is what makes
it the Brier variation other moves here
are Knight a5 and Bishop b7 those are
also playable good night b8 and then now
there's enough force in the center for
white to play d4 he has pretty
sufficient piece development so he's
gonna try and bust open the center black
is not yet prepared for white to capture
on e5 it's only protected once and
attacked twice so he moves his night
from b8 to d7 and that was one of the
points of Knight to be 8 in the first
place he's gonna try and go Knight d7
Knight f8 and then Knight g6
and here white is gonna have the same
type of slow plant
he's trying to figure out how to develop
his pieces in the most optimal way
is gonna be bringing the night over to
the kingside and then trying to get all
these pieces on the kingside try an
attack so Knight B to d2 and black goes
Bishop to b7 he's putting pressure on e4
and we need to try and protect efore
because it's attacked twice it's
defended twice but we want to try and
have a defender playing with this Knight
is to go to f1 so we go Bishop to see
two black trying to keep up with his
plan they're gonna go rook e8 to allow
Knight to f8 Dwight continues with
Knight f1 and here black notices white
is trying to go to g3 and he tries to
think how can we stop White's pieces
from being so active if white moves his
knight to g3 it's looking at coming to
f5 and h5 it can't go to h5 right away
but watch I'm limit these squares for
the white tonight so black is gonna try
and prepare g6 and make his pieces
revolver on that if his Knight goes to
f8 it won't be able to go to g6 because
the pawn will be there slowly moves
Bishop to f8 after g6 he's gonna try and
put the bishop on g7 here white
continues Knight g3 and then g6
restricting the night White has
completed his plan on the King side his
two very well placed Knights both of his
bishops are facing this direction so
he's gonna try and gain expansion on the
Queen side try and get some advantage
over there so he's gonna go a 4 and
black counter strikes in the center with
c5 and white wants to shut this down
shut this idea down keep a space
advantage and trying to convert to a win
so you're gonna go d5 and then black
trying to keep his Center solid is gonna
place c5 and this is the Brier opening
both sides are going to be trying to
slowly develop their pieces and it's all
going to be a fight over the center the
most common continuation will be Bishop
to g5 h6 and Bishop to e3 all of whites
pieces have a purpose all of blacks
pieces also have a purpose
because it's not the best opening for
black it doesn't have a very good score
but hopefully this gives you guys some
idea of how the pieces develop and work
together so that is it for the rule
apes' or prior defense
[Music]